1917 l'Ukraine pour la première fois en
200 ans de domination devient
indépendante quand l’empire russe
s'effondre pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale et la révolution bolchevique
pas pour longtemps après quatre années
de guerre civile Moscou reprend le
contrôle de l'Ancien Empire des sables
l'Ukraine et les régions russes d'une
première famille mais Lénine réaliste
lance sa nouvelle politique économique
la NEP pour rallier les populations au
bolchevisme libre marché pour les
fermiers Ukrainiens qui constituent 80%
de la population
l'Ukraine riche grenier de l'Europe
prospère à nouveau pour la première fois
depuis le 17e siècle l'église orthodoxe
ukrainienne Renée mais tout se fait en
ukrainien Saint Joseph Staline ne le
supporte pas après la mort de Lénine en
1924 il met en place un état centraliste
totalitaire
c'est ce qu'illustre le documentaire la
moisson du désespoir le Holodomor le
génocide ukrainien du centre
ukraino-canadien de recherche et du
documentation et donc quand on dit ça
vient de deux mots et mort épuisement
épuisement par la fin ou pas la famille
romane Serbie n'a rien introduit et
commenté le texte fondamental sur le
génocide ukrainien publié en 1953 par le
juriste polonais Raphaël Lemkin en 33
langues c'est le Kin qui a forgé la
notion et le terme de génocide codifié
par les Nations Unies en 1948 et mise en
œuvre par Staline en Ukraine et il avait
préparé une politique pour exterminer
les éliminer les élites
nationaux puis Staline confisque toutes
les terres des paysans obligés de
travailler dans les fermes collectives
l'école causes les paysans qui résistent
les coulaques sont déportés ou éliminés
toutes les récoltes de l'Ukraine sont
réquisitionnées après c'est la famille
prête en 1933 le génocide par la fin
atteint son point culminant 25000
meurent chaque jour Staline voulait-il
éliminer tous les Ukrainiens pour romane
serbine il voulait plutôt de les
transformer en D ce qu'il appelait les
lois je les vis du Grand mécanisme de
l'Empire qui était qui s'appelait à
cette époque la ligne soviétique
conclusion de Rafael Lemkin il ne s'agit
pas simplement d'un cas de meurtre de
masse il s'agit d'un cas de génocide de
destruction non seulement des individus
mais d'une culture d'une nation
le 22 novembre dernier 9 mois après
l'invasion russe le président Zelinski
commémore le horlogue de mort au
mémorial du génocide en compagnie des
dirigeants de la Belgique et de la
Lituanie
cette fois-ci l'Occident semble décider
à ne pas fermer les yeux et à résister à
une nouvelle tentative d'annihiler la
nation ukrainienne de nier son existence
afin de reconstituer l'ancienne empire
des tsars et de Staline
[Musique]